une annonce du ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire qu'il engage à tenir ses
engagements selon ellen la porte porte
parole de la candidate et rennes à
l'élection présidentielle marine le pen
c'est une promesse qui a été faite par
le gouvernement qui devrait plafonner à
4% de hausse d'énergie on est à quelques
mandats présidentiels mais c'est surtout
au delà de ça préserver le pouvoir
d'achat des français qui est déjà mise à
rude épreuve je rappelle en même temps
qu'il ya un sondage une étude plutôt de
secours populaire qui a dit que un
français sur quatre ne mange pas à sa
faim
l'énergie c'est pas un produit de luxe
c'est un produit de nécessité
se chauffer ça fait partie des choses
qui sont enfin qui sont indispensables à
la vie de chacun donc oui les le
gouvernement n'a pas le choix mais j'ai
envie de dire c'est surtout être correct
et honnête vis-à-vis de ce qui a été
promis aux français mais c'est surtout
la méthode moi finalement qui me gêne
derrière sur comment est mise en place
cette mesure même bruno le maire est
d'accord avec nous sur ce point là on ne
peut pas continuer laisser bruxelles
réglementée à l'intérieur de notre pays
la tarification des tristes et notamment